there are two types of Fire Emblem
players those who gravitate towards the
social mechanics and those who prefer
the Tactical turn-based combat after a
guided demo Fire Emblem engage seems
like it may cater more towards the
latter while the social Sim aspects are
still intact there seems to be far fewer
extraneous activities in the hub area
compared to three houses a lot of your
time at the Hub is spent outfitting your
party members unlocking new combat
skills and preparing for the next battle
in this way Fire Emblem engage feels
like a more focused take on the
long-running Tactical jrpg series Fire
Emblem engage follows a similar
structure to other modern Fire Emblem
games your time is split between the
Tactical tile based combat in a hub area
where you can interact with other
characters on the battlefield Fire
Emblem engage brings back the
traditional weapon triangle that this
series is known for swords beat axes
axes beat Spears and Spears beat swords
taking advantage of the weapon triangle
inflicts break which prevents the
defending unit from countering in a
skirmish weapons outside of the triangle
such as bows daggers and spell tomes are
weak to physical attacks as much as I
enjoyed three houses I played nearly 200
hours of it I did miss the traditional
weapon triangle in past games it gave
specific weapons distinct strengths and
weaknesses that forced me to carefully
consider my party the reintroduction of
this classic mechanic could lead to a
more balanced experience especially for
those who might have felt three houses
was a bit too easy at the center of
engage's combat is the engage mechanic
as you progress through the story you
unlock emblem rings that can be equipped
on any party member each emblem ring
houses the spirit of a character from a
previous Fire Emblem game and when given
to a party member they combine for
improved stats and some powerful
abilities you can mix emblem rings with
any character in your party for varying
effects and strategies some combinations
can lead to incredibly mobile party
members While others could significantly
buff a character strength stat some
combinations may work better than others
but every party member can forge bonds
with every classic character housed in
an emblem ring like bonds formed between
units bonds between party members and
emblem Rings increase the effectiveness
of that pair every Mainline Fire Emblem
game is represented via emblem Rings
some of the returning Fire Emblem
characters I saw in the demo included
Ike Lucina Roy Marth Lynn sigurd and
Celica additionally there are items
called Bond rings that can be equipped
in place of emblem Rings these Rings
feature characters from previous games
and Grant passive Buffs spawn rings can
be accumulated through a gotcha style
Mini-Game after you've equipped your
party you can activate the engage
mechanic by pressing the plus button
before kicking off a skirmish while
active the classic Fire Emblem character
embedded in the equipped emblem ring
will accompany that unit after three
turns are up you will need to refill
your engage meter through combat I
didn't have enough time to experiment
with different emblem rings but it seems
like this could lead to some really
interesting combinations there are also
a handful of tweaks to the
moment-to-moment combat as well most
notably now you have direct control over
a character's movement rather than
selecting a unit and plotting a path for
them you can freely move around the
battle before committing to a tile and
attacking it's not a huge change but it
does give you a little more flexibility
and precision to your movements Fire
Emblem engage also does away with weapon
durability once you find or purchase a
weapon it's yours to keep hopefully this
change means we'll be spending less time
managing a unit's inventory and more
time battling enemies and chatting up
comrades now I am curious to see how the
game's economy is balanced now that you
don't need to keep buying weapons as
they break on the battlefield most of
your time outside of the battlefield is
spent at the somnil your home base here
you can interact with your party members
and heroes from past Fire Emblem games
manage an animal pen complete with
adorable pups partake in some weight
training for temporary stat Buffs cook
me meals to build relationships with
other characters and upgrade your emblem
rings that said there is a lot to dig
into when it comes to emblem Rings each
emblem ring has an upgrade path for each
character in your crew these upgrade
paths can give a character permanent
stat boosts and new skills that are
unique to a specific emblem ring there
is a dizzying amount of combinations
here that should give players plenty of
flexibility I only had a few minutes to
look this over but I could have easily
spent an hour digging into all the
upgrade paths and considering my options
aside from the emblem Rings there is a
large cast of characters you can take
into battle level up and customize I
didn't play nearly enough of the game to
form any solid opinions on the
characters I did see but many of the
traditional jrpg anime archetypes seem
to be here there's a heroic strong man
with a shield and a feisty petite Mage
just to name a few hopefully like other
Fire Emblem games these characters
develop beyond their trappings but that
remains to be seen what is immediately
clear is that fire engage looks great
the Nintendo switch has had a rough year
when it comes to Performance and visuals
but Fire Emblem and gauge pops right off
the screen thanks to its vibrant color
palette and Lively character animations
the cell shaded art style from three
houses is back and it feels as though
it's been cleaned up quite a bit here
now the slant away from social Sim
mechanics from three houses might
disappoint some but the refined combat
and reintroduction of the weapon
triangle should excite longtime fans and
Gage also looks and feels incredibly
deep and I look forward to diving head
first into all of its mechanics and
tactical Nuance on January 20th 2023.
for more on Fire Emblem engage stay
tuned to GameSpot